charlie is off and will go to nora in
houston in just a moment you know she
had to move locations because of the
intensity of the storm and we could no
longer see her on camera so that's a
problem she's going to a new location
and officials now say the worst of the
flooding in houston is still
two or three days away oh no the
country's fourth largest city is already
facing what could be one of the worst
flooding disasters in american history
and at least two deaths are blamed on
hurricane harvey and its aftermath
hundreds of streets and highways can
only be navigated by boat thousands of
people stranded in their homes have been
rescued authorities have had trouble
though identifying the hardest hit areas
the national weather service says some
parts of the houston area could get 50
inches of rain that's more than four
feet before the storm is finished nora
o'donnell is now across from the
convention center in downtown houston
nora good morning once again
hey good morning to you maurice you know
we were actually here last night there
were about 700 people inside that
shelter we just checked in with the red
cross they now say there are
2500 people inside of that shelter there
what's noteworthy about that we got the
first look at some of the cuts that they
were setting up they set up 1200 cops
cots rather they maxed out that's all
they have in terms of the bed so that
means about half of the people did not
have beds last night largely just
camping out on the ground they're just
they weren't quite frankly prepared they
didn't have they weren't set up
yesterday morning the red cross did the
best job they could all day long to set
up the 1200 cots that they did and
provide for them so they are maxing out
in capacity here we should also mention
that it's just now but the sun is just
rising here so we're going to be getting
our first look at some of the
devastation this morning there was a lot
of rain last night and we know that this
catastrophic situation is only going to
get worse here's the update from the
national weather service they said that
this is beyond anything it has ever
experienced the head of fema said just a
short time ago this morning that the
houston area will probably get another
13 to 20 inches of rain over the next
several days
to me that's just incomprehensible to
think about where that water is going to
go and the flooding will max out on
wednesday or thursday and then it will
finally start to recede very slowly the
fema administration administrator also
predicts more than 30 000 people will
need temporary shelter we've seen just
here though it's more than they expected
just at this one location now the army
corps of engineers started a controlled
release of water overnight from
reservoirs that usually protect downtown
houston from flooding now that will make
the flooding worse for neighborhoods
around those reservoirs specifically
along the buffalo bayou which is where i
was just a short time ago in which we
had to leave that area now the army says
that releasing pressure on those
reservoirs will prevent an
uncontrollable wall of water that would
be heading for the right the heart of
the city so they're trying to save
downtown essentially
but that's going to result in flooding
of some other homes